Great, we understand the data model or
managed object model.
Now on to the rest of these.
It's important to remember
that these seven classes
always work together as a team
called the CoreDataStack.
As such, it's very useful to treat them
as a team as opposed to individuals.
We can therefore keep
the whole team in one class,
oddly enough called CoreDataStack.
Even though in our day to day,
we will use this class without
thinking too much about what's inside,
it's worth taking a look at
the code to see what makes it tick.
Note that this class is pretty much
what Apple provides you with, so
don't feel bad for using it as is.
It's the boilerplate class from
the Apple developers' site on CoreData.
Let's start with the initializer,
it's job is as follows.
It reads a model file, and
this is the extension of the model
file once it has been
compiled by X code, momd.
Then it creates a sqlite store for
it inside the documents folder.
And it will call it model.sqlite.
Once it's done,
it initializes a context and
connects all these necessary parts
into a persistent store coordinator.
The coordinator will
also perform migrations.
That's something that
we'll deal with later.
And if everything goes okay,
we get no errors.
We exit, and we have all the core
data stack ready to work.
There are several utility
methods that are available here,
so just drop all data.
This will delete all the objects
inside of your sqlite store.
But it won't delete the files,
so it just empties the tables.
This is useful while you're developing.
And we also have
the save context method,
which builds on top of the method save
from the context in the following way.
Whenever you call save context,
it will first check if there is any
changes that have to be
saved,and then will save.
So this will make our stack
a little bit more performing.
There are other features that we will
need such as migrating data models or
implementing an auto save.
We'll add them along the way
when they become necessary.
Let's get started.